hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alva
I'm John Humphrey we have gotten back
from comic-con late last night brake
pads don't work cat is sick it's still
got a catch up on YouTube and patreon to
do's it's a good week coming out of us
haha blocked everything with sarcasm
we're gonna catch up with The Witcher
today before we go into that I wanted to
say thank you to the folks over at dark
web once again probably last I'm gonna
mention this for sponsoring some videos
for our channel last week and of course
invited me to moderate your panel or
your eight episode exclusive series on
Amazon the panel was a lot of fun a
whole lot of fun might be able to upload
some clips under our patreon page thank
you to everyone who came out for that
the show is a serialized anthology
series where it follows a story about a
missing person but every episode weaves
in a tale from the dark web they're all
so damn unique the response has been so
damn positive we attended the screening
for the first night where they premiered
the first four episodes in front of a
live audience it was fun just watching
that crowd react to so much of what was
going on the show a whole lot of people
lined up to do the Q&A and there's
already as much a positive reviews up on
Amazon so yeah I am happy to have worked
with you guys thank you again and please
go check out dark web and then
afterwards
prepare yourself for The Witcher
the main stories don't we just sit -
mother say
those are the original sources of the
continent but humans are monsters
arriving else to humans have to come
cast at the magic
[Music]
chaos is the most dangerous thing I
forget it
[Music]
this child
extraordinary
[Music]
[Music]
because are terrified of it
[Music]
I
[Music]
what you choose
[Music]
lady
[Music]
whoa let's get some monsters
demon-possession black school in our
eyes oh yeah you know it's a demon when
they got that going on the like weird
veiny sort of under skin yeah that's
pretty cool so if this turns out great
is this gonna be considered a great
adaptation of the book or is it gonna be
considered the first great video game
adaptation I think it's gonna carry an
asterisk and it's gonna be kind of
acknowledged for sort of doing both
until they start to go into exact game
territory at which point the Astor's
will go away know how interesting that
what you think of the show John uh I
mean it's kind of what I expected based
on what's been described to me I know
this is what Netflix wants to be their
game of Thrones and they want it to I
imagine also rival their lore the Rings
show that's coming out from Amazon so I
mean it definitely looks like it has
that production value that scope I like
the look of Henry Cavill and I like that
they keep him kind of mysterious in this
trailer I know some people have
complained about the lack of dialogue he
gets in this why I don't really with the
people who do I haven't followed any
news on what's going on with Henry
Cavill not a bunch but I know some
people like but yeah I don't know is it
just an intro to the world an intro to
the lore I thought it was pretty cool
I'm still you know gonna wait for the
show to see what makes it truly unique I
like the idea of having a game of
Thrones style is show with more monster
focus and seeing that big creature at
the end got me probably the most I think
what Game of Thrones has done they've
really established themselves as
whatever show takes place at a time
period like this will automatically be
called like they're trying to do that
are booking their own Game of Thrones
but weirdly it wasn't flashing in Game
of Thrones during this maybe because
it's so fantasy heavy this series and I
remember like with Game of Thrones in
the beginning it's not very fantasy
heavy there's like light fantasy and
then there's more fantasy that slowly
gets infused over time we're here this
seems to be really leading with that you
know monsters a lot of action a lot of
superpowers presented throughout and
that all looks really cool to me and I
would have liked to have seen I guess
the only missing
for me from this trailer was a little
bit more of its heart our esque type of
qualities here you know because I see I
haven't played The Witcher video game
I've seen a lot of footage from it I've
seen a lot of gameplay footage from it
you know like let's see some of that I
mean not maybe no sexual stuff now
because you know how you too can be one
that to be confirmed and all that to
really be at play here to really push
the boundaries in terms of what you do
with the Netflix show Henry Cavill is
doing I guess I'm not upset by the lack
of dialogue because it's he's doing
exactly what I expect him to do with
this role just brooding and sexy and
that wig doesn't look awkward and in
terms of movement he looks cool the two
girls that they were really focusing a
lot on in this trailer they look great
they look like more of the stars of the
show they look awesome here oh yeah well
I guess that's gonna be part of the main
tale as he sort of meets up with these
two I know one of them's like a princess
and they're basically on this journey
together so I'm also you know curious
about what the relationship drama is
gonna be like with them you know if he
has to take on some kind of fatherly
role or learn to look out if he's gonna
be like gruff and be like I don't need
you guys are gonna slow me down but then
you know maybe becoming more of a
character or something I wonder with
this series if they're gonna be with
people who haven't played the game or
the books are gonna be more inclined to
go and play the game to prepare for the
show or read the books
I've heard it said that this is directly
I think based on the books that precede
the games so if you're playing the game
is to prepare from what I understand
you're probably not gonna be you're
wasting your time you'll get the world
but maybe no don't boy the video game
you play the video and in terms of you
know like the comparison to things like
Game of Thrones the upcoming Lord of the
Rings show this looks on par in terms of
production design yeah I think the
lighting in this show is quite striking
this seems to be maybe not up there with
Game of Thrones but above shows like
Vikings which already look amazing you
know yeah you know just like one light
one quality snotch above it all I wonder
if people who make these period epic
shows like start to borrow each other's
sets after a while they're like notice
here that down
we'll just change a couple of the walls
and we'll use this castle and then we'll
use this epic Ridge or something like
that you know well I guess what I have
no idea how the show will play out in
terms of is its tone and pacing that's
something that I think can be very
important for a show like this to work
it's gonna be six episodes a six episode
oh you're making it I'm going on over
this final joke it's eight episodes I
think yeah Corrin everyone's IMDb so for
one person who's credited for nine years
there's a clip show episode hosted by
that one character it's an 8 episode
series which I feel like is the right
amount 8 to 10 has become the sweet spot
yeah and I think for this show that
would be perfect but but there's needs
to be a lot of chaotic things going on I
imagine some stuff is being told through
explaining former legacies before we're
at the time that we're at now I just
would like this show to you know not be
boring but take its time developmental
world and its mythologies and yeah yeah
really really jumping you in and I'm
just assuming that you are a die-hard
fan of either Witcher 3 or the books
that would be the biggest mistake they
make is only servicing that you have to
reintroduce this to a bunch of people
but there's also seems to be so much
craziness in terms of supernatural
things at play the thing I am concerned
about is the tone and pacing of the show
I mean people fans seem pretty excited
about it so that gives me hope yeah from
everything I've seen I'm like it looks
like things I've seen before it looks
like what I know about The Witcher yeah
and that's so that's exciting but at the
same time that's not even for those fans
it won't be enough by the time it comes
to dedicating eight hours of televisions
good alright guys well are you excited
for The Witcher leave your thoughts down
below thanks for letting us cover this
leg just kind of impossible to cover
everything really underestimate how to
do it all subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell and also
let's give a patient the day shout out
to a man named Philip J Smith jr. here
we go I'm gonna read our messages check
out how intense and long they are I'm
like hey Philip its Greg how are you
buddy
thanks for pledging to our patreon page
I see we owe you a shout out in our
future vid help us give you
proper Oh mate where are you from Long
Island New York Oh awesome
I have some family out there what would
you say your passion is in amigo being a
volunteer firefighter helping people out
keep having exclamation literally on the
career I've ever considered outside of
fellows being a firefighter Oh what are
parents do for a living
both my parents are retired now and I
was 23 minutes
Wow so clearly he shares the same
enthusiasm for talking he's just really
nervous you know he doesn't want to
embarrass himself in front of you he
doesn't want to say something silly I'm
glad your volunteer firefighter that's
something I wish I wish I ballin tier 4
anything is that the matter you
volunteer for something is beautiful to
me firefighting is like the coolest of
the law enforcement if any cops or
paramedics and of the law enforcement
the public sir public services yeah I
don't know what to call it's not a lot
of things for not in fire it's just good
advice you know whatever you got the
coolest one Phillip thanks for being
here hope you appreciate your shout out
cuz you gave me plenty to work with